dans ces quelques rues d'apparence
banale transitent chaque année des
milliards d'euros de pierres précieuses
nous sommes dans le quartier des
diamantaires à anvers où l'on cherche à
se faire discret depuis le début de la
guerre en ukraine
environ 95% des diamants bruts qui entre
dans l'union européenne arrivent ici
dans cette rue est à peu près un tiers
sont d'origine russe des importations
qui ne font toujours pas l'objet de
sanctions européennes
ce chercheur travaille pour une ong
membres du processus de kimberley une
organisation qui vise à lutter contre
les diamants de conflits depuis
l'invasion de l'ukraine certaines voix
s'élèvent pour enquêter sur la filière
russe en ligne de mire alrosa un groupe
minier détenu à plus de 30% par le
kremlin
récemment il ya eu des rapports qui
mettait en lumière des liens plus
directs d'alrosa qui serait une
entreprise qui contribuerait à
l'appareil militaire et nucléaire russe
ce sont des éléments qui doivent être
examinées plus en détails pour le moment
l'union européenne a sanctionné les
exportations de diamants taillés vers la
russie insuffisant pour cette militante
qui appellent à plus de sévérité
notamment pour pallier les feuilles du
processus de kimberley a des limites au
niveau du processus kimberley notamment
à ce qui concerne la définition de ce
processus qui sera faire uniquement aux
groupes rebelles dans le cas de la
russie on n'a pas affaire à des groupes
rebelles qui financerait le conflit via
le commerce des diamants mais bien à des
forces gouvernementales
mais pour ce professeur d'économie
anciennement proche de l'industrie
diamantaire des sanctions qu'unir est
avant tout le secteur européen déjà
fortement concurrencée par d'autres pays
de soule holebi fact et ce ne serait
effectif que si ces sanctions étaient
adoptées par tous
mais on sait que l'inde dubaï ou encore
israël n'adopte pas les mêmes fonctions
le résultat ce serait seulement que
l'europe perdrait une industrie
importante
de leur côté les états unis ont imposé
des sanctions sur les importations de
diamants bruts venus de russie mais
difficile pourtant d'imaginer un boycott
total puisque une fois taillé il est
impossible de déterminer l'origine de
certaines pierres